takis over here today if feelings are
running high in Los Angeles 22 years to
the day after this city erupted in race
riots this was a measured response to a
whole new provocation you're associating
with black people the voice of Donald
sterling owner of the Los Angeles
Clippers basketball team in a recording
obtained by TMZ sports allegedly talking
to his girlfriend and now banned for
life by the sport's governing body step
up it do was right for the black
community brothers that's what she's
supposed to be doing he's making money
off of the blacks and become a
three-time billionaire off of the
plaques and I was shocked that you had
that much hatred toward blacks and you
make an artist money off the black you
think they did the right thing today in
banning him for life
absolutely multiple counts over
selfishly as a clipper fan as a fan of
the team as a fan of the players in the
coach I'm thrilled dark cloud lifted
that age group of whites they felt
superior to blacks and that we we what
we were subservient to them and it seems
like he still has that same mentality
the fans protesting outside wore black
to show their solidarity basketball
bosses will now try to force Sterling to
sell the Clippers they say there's no
place for him in the game I urge the
Board of Governors to exercise its
authority to force a sale of the team
and we'll do everything in my power to
ensure that that happens this story has
touched everyone from President Obama
down through sports stars and music
stars and of course ordinary fans and
reminded everyone just how powerful the
issue of race still is even in
modern-day America it's a great day for
you know the United States it was a
great day for the NBA is a great day for
all people of all races but especially
you know african-americans Latinos
the Clippers website contained a simple
message even the organization welcoming
the decision what they believe here is
justice being done Gregg Milam Sky News
Los Angeles